[Musica]
e menù più ansiolitico che io abbia mai
visto in un videogioco però è la tutti
ragazzi venuti a questo video sono
famigerati siamo su unforgiven a nord e
il titolo non so che cosa cazzo negative
dalla prima all'ultima parola prova bene
anche questo c'è una cosa o dio dove son
mica perché grafica cha sto gioco dio
pensavo d'essere st grafite qua vabbè se
mica rotto ma secondo me si sa i devo
trovare aiuto ma devo trovare una scheda
grafica nuova prima di tutto altro che
aiuta a parte la scheda grafica a muover
ma non vedo niente non c'e la torcia
finalmente un videogioco che mette alla
prova il mio computer da youtube e così
vedete quanto professionale sono
equipaggiato per questo bellissimo
lavoro che faccio che effetto sonoro era
pensavo di averli di giuro su dio che
queste cuffie sembrava di averla in
stanza mi son cagato ho una casa c'è una
che sa io pensavo di essere su un'isola
deserta ma che figata su un ponte che
tra l'altro ci ho messo una vita non
ebbe è la madonna prima gara di me sta
tizia cos'è sta roba
una centrale con l'accendino va bene
quindi posso possa accendere l'accendino
ok da fuoco al ponte perché sono un
piromane perfetto ma che figata che ciò
ma che storia o d'altro vena o un
cappello in testa ho la testa le forme
credo
magari la prossima volta guardo dove
vado e non guardo la mia ombra cosa le
vite ragazzi è andata subito a farsi
[ __ ] l'idea di arrivare sulla casetta
anche perché era una cosa fighissima c'è
il fattore c soggetto non ci incazziamo
è che è la madonna è passata amica una
ragazza col ciclo di qua perché potrebbe
tranquillamente essere ragazzi comunque
non solo ma chi è che ha scaricato gli
alberi no no no no non ti svegli
schifosa maledetta una cosa non doveva
succedere questa poi grazie a dio c'è un
altro cosa fai abbastanza veloce che
sente un rumore bruttissimo
ecco perché i treni trenitalia arrivano
in ritardo porca eva passato tutti i
liquami
io per non saper né leggere né scrivere
vado a funghi seguiamo i funghi i
ragazzi deve essere la strada per
amsterdam
devo essere decisamente fatto di funghi
per riuscire a trovare qualcosa di bello
in questo posto oppure per entrare lì
dentro anche lì perché per quello deve
essere fatto ma c'era finiti visti
accendini qua ma perché veramente durano
un secondo e mezzo cioè troppo
realistico sto gioco di accendini non
dura un cazzo un po come quando fai il
sesso
grazie per la musica di tensione in
continuo aumento giusto per non
ammontare l'ansa che già ciò grazie
mille ma chi è che qual è il treno che
passa di qua non spiegate quel problema
magari era magari non passa un treno che
volevo andare in casa era molto bello
questo gioco all'inizio c'era una casa
una [ __ ] casa niente ma ancora roba
così semplice sono riuscito a fare
fantastico tutto questo e l'accendino
sta andando a [ __ ]
quindi prima trovò nato kosanost i
rumori che sento ogni tanto
lo sono i soldi del monopoly cos'è sta
roba
non so ma mi ami è finita due cose che
non devono succedere lo stesso momento
sono successe
no ragazzi oddio meno male che mi vedo
le tette
cos'è non mi può svegliarsi non si può
spendere fiammifero e passarmi qualcuno
l'ha nudo davanti al pub e non vedo
niente tocca qualcuno vedo nulla
non vedo niente c'è il buio pesto vedo
solo le mie tette che per quanto sia
piacevole non è d'aiuto o tiro
impossibile camminare al buio non fai
nulla neanche un metro
dall'altro il tizio di prima dove
dovevano ornarsi novese
bye bye bye bye e io siamo dunque a
vedere ma che [ __ ] sono guarda sono
già lì
non mi piace quando senti stesso re dei
bubboni no diciamo che non è perfetto
grande è proprio quello che mi serviva
in questo momento non sarebbe che il
tasto click over accendono proprio picco
e tutti i tasti a caso fai te
[Musica]
ma per chi ne va bene
e l'ho vista si è perfetta la brava è
accendi accenti è una nuda e una nuda
non è neanche mia morchio a della ti
pago il ciclone si sa che le ragazze
condono ciclo hanno fame sapevo io sia
va bene che si è abituata al mcdonald
però in questo caso per caso siamo c'è
un torrente qui a vedere il braccio
porca eva che schifo e altre
[Musica]
erano veramente forti quei funghi li
porca eva deve esserci satana
sicuramente se seguo queste notai e
papua quasi convinto però va bene budan
[Musica]
7 nov
conosco la canzone adatta per questi
momenti caro amico mio
perché parlano gli alberi tre problemi
occhi da fuoco
schifoso di vento beccano e vi ammazzo
ti devi togliere devo prendere il tuo
bambino ma è un mio ma è un'anguria
marcia
dite che succeda il mio braccio successo
braccio e lavato anna sto diventando
anche un albero è prendi prendi prendi
erano stato fuoco la scusa via cavo ha
detto io che vi avrei dato fuoco
ve lo meritate è un po accento un po
stronzi devono sofia sofia che passa in
mente un soffio anno passa in mezzo
anche i bar chi se ne frega non temo il
fuoco a bada momento calze a lungo su
muro perfetto inizia non vedere più
niente quando non vedo più niente
fantasma vedo la luce se questa si può
chiamare luce si può uscire dio ti
ringrazio che brutto quarto d'ora che ho
passato la dentro è stato orribile
ringrazio dio siamo usciti
[Musica]
maghette acque vaio buonisti funghi
hagrid siamo nella foresta proibita di
harry potter salute ma semplici passi ma
non lo vedo pensate questo messo male
peccato volevo far conoscenza
probabilmente sono ancora bella [ __ ] che
problemi ed i file e le braccia zia abel
dà il meglio del solito
ok allora ragazzi il problema non è
questo eccola abbiamo girato il ponte ma
vero ma c'è io ho dovuto affrontare i
demoni e satana l'inferno perché è
crollato un ponte di merda questo mi
stai dicendo
cioè io potevo passare i guai ero già
arrivava a [ __ ] permesso
guarda se non mi fai entrata ammazzo
niente posta la domenica mamma morder
son affaccia rogazzo del morden ma morse
proprio to the hands benson eric
henderson permesso ah beh chiudi si può
chiudere a chiave che non è proprio il
massimo questo posto aveva ci vuole poco
cos'era apri apri la porta cosa è
successo non morde nelle persone che io
devo entrare nelle stanze buie bello
guarda al fantastico ma insieme è la
madonna è incazzata forte questa ragazza
con chick molto di più di quanto
pensassi dottor martin sec papa for two
films grazie papà da porco a sonagli
famiglia che penso proprio di no
mi sono pagato in è la madonna dove era
sul tetto
ok posso finire qua al gioco guarda
quando scendi toni sono contento almeno
vedo si può concludere questo episodio
basta non pensavo fosse fatto così bene
un indigene non sono fatti così mi
chiamo ed ora che scout last ragazzi
manca poco è makan due settimane poi
siamo tutti nella merda che la di una
vacca laita schifosa maledetta cazzo
revi gagarin
chiamo lo sto andando raga non vedo
perche la corri corri corri dolcissimo e
vabbè che cazzo corri giacca slalom tra
gli altri non ti raggiunge veloce c'è
una tipa c'è la tipa che sono al violino
suona gliela lui il violino e la madonna
[Musica]
mai stato così contento di sentire una
canzone così brutta
era quella la mamma che si è trasformata
perché c'è stato un morso quindi anch'io
mi trasformerò così thank you for plague
things to get bello sto gioco ma
bellissimo a bel taglio di capelli a
giugno va bene ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto è un gioco figo ma molto figo
per deve essere un horror normale tranne
la tipa alla fine che era un po
sovrappeso però le ragazze che non sia
piaciuto come senso che per il momento
mi piace anche marco venire descrizione
non si siano resi vediamo sports cup
ho preso è lurido ci vediamo al prossimo
video belle ragazze
[Musica]